alors pouvez-vous me parler des locataires
qui vivent en face de mrs.
lonnigan
je ne l'ai jamais rencontrée ouvrez-vous
s'il vous plaît NYPD elle ne sort jamais c'est un
peu étrange eh bien c'est une sorte de
cercle monsieur rien ne semblait étrange autour de
son nom est Justine waters connue comme
la petite chérie
unique héritière de la fortune des eaux elle
mystérieusement  disparu il y a 17 ans
ce mois-ci ce qui est intéressant c'est de
traverser le couloir elle n'a pas de
numéro de sécurité sociale rien qu'elle
n'ait laissé depuis plus de 4 millions d'années elle
ressemblait à une victime il n'y a que deux
unités au niveau penthouse si j'étais
toi  Je ferais un geste que pensez-vous que
je ne suis rien
ils ont loué l'appartement
juste que je ne veux pas que les choses changent
tu dois me faire confiance ils vont mener
leur vie comme Hillary que la sienne
tu as besoin de repos
si tu l'es  qui je pense que tu es ici
au centre de quelque chose de très dangereux
tu dois le faire maintenant
nous attendons Charlie je ne
veux pas fuir les flics
je ne fais pas d'erreurs pour un e-mail loin
d'une fortune